The
system.
It's under strain.
And we're seeing manifestation of that
is and the rise of the independent voter
registration.
I think the political system,
if you look at here in Washington from
the governing standpoint,
it's clearly broken.
We're at gridlock on every issue.
We fail to address issues of
irresponsible spending or Medicare,
social security,
and we don't do any of the hard things.
Um,
we spend,
we're in a continuous battle over the
war in Iraq and,
uh,
partisanship and bitterness is probably
as high level as I've seen it in all my
years here,
that we sit down together for the good
of the country.
I know how to work across cio with
Democrats.
So I have for many years as president,
I will reach across my hand,
across the aisle to the Democrats,
and I'll ask them to reach across to me
and I'll ask the American people to urge
him to do so.
If we get things accomplished,
then obvious him all the credit.